astronomers believe that every century a
few stars in the milky way explode as
supernovae blasting out a brightly
glowing cloud of gas and dust and firing
particles in all directions
most of these events are too far from
earth to impact us but if one happened
nearby the effect could be dramatic
new evidence suggests that in the past
few million years at least two
supernovae occurred close to earth
dusting it with radioactive nuclei
the question is were they near enough to
impact life on our planet
astronomers now hypothesize that several
million years ago a barrage of
supernova-generated particles known as
cosmic rays could have depleted the
ozone layer increased cancer rates
sparked wildfires and even started an
ice age
most supernovae occur when stars run out
of fuel and collapse under their own
gravity the shock of the implosion
blasts debris far into space some of
that debris eventually reaches
neighboring star systems and settles on
planets
among this material are radioactive
isotopes like iron 60 with half-lives of
millions of years too young to have been
there since the earth formed 4.5 billion
years ago
scientists have now found traces of iron
60 in ocean crusts antarctic snow and
even in lunar soil all deposited from
far away stars
these deposits suggest local supernovae
occurred 2.5 and 6 million years ago
the dusting of atoms would not be
noticed by any inhabitants of earth but
supernovae have other effects the
initial blast full of x-rays and gamma
rays could be lethal at very close range
but even from a few hundred light years
away a supernova can still pack a slow
burning punch
some scientists think the blast 2.5
million years ago was close enough to
have substantially changed the evolution
of our planet
supernovae produced cosmic rays
particles like protons accelerated to
near light speed which could have
wreaked havoc on earth's biosphere
the rays from the most recent supernova
may have depleted the earth's ozone
layer letting in more of the sun's
ultraviolet light
reactions in the stratosphere may have
increased fertilizing nitrogen oxide
compounds leading to a surge in plant
growth that could have cooled the
climate helping to initiate an ice age
and animals may have felt the
supernova's effects directly when cosmic
rays hit the upper atmosphere they
generate showers of particles including
muons heavy short-lived cousins of
electrons that can penetrate deep into
animal tissue
organisms on earth would have received
triple the normal dose of radiation from
these muons increasing their risk of
cancer
these showers of particles would also
leave tracks of ionized air molecules as
they streak through the atmosphere
creating pathways for lightning that may
have sparked wildfires across the globe
finding the real culprits for the recent
supernovae is impossible as they fade to
near invisibility after tens of
thousands of years
but astronomers have tracked a group of
nearby stars a few dozen in total and
wound back the clock to see where they
were 2.5 million years ago
sure enough they swung within 300 light
years of earth at the time from the ages
of surviving members of the group it's
likely some would have been ripe for
explosion just the right place in time
to dust earth with atoms and maybe do
more damage
the exact effects of supernovae on earth
remain speculative
some scientists suggest the blast caused
extinctions while others think those
events had unrelated causes
for now more research is needed to
determine how supernovae may have
changed earth's timeline
so next time you look up at the stars be
thankful you weren't alive 2.5 million
years ago when a supernova lit up the
sky
[Music]